for his views on Greece let's turn to
Joseph Stiglitz he is of course the
Nobel prize-winning economist and author
of the book the Great Divide where
professor Stiglitz talks about
inequality thank you so much for coming
here on the program so we'll keep you
for at 40 minutes we have a lot of
things to talk about Greece how do you
deal with Greece you have two parts
they've never really been this far apart
and and the clock is ticking and yet no
one seems to be willing to give it and
who's going to win or is everyone going
to lose well I mean there is risk that
everybody is going to lose you know I've
looked at the kinds of reforms that
you've already done it's actually very
impressive the macro economic reforms
the bringing down the deficit in terms
of the actions but on the other hand if
your economy improves which the
austerity has caused we should be very
clear it was the austerity that really
brought the economy down 25 percent
below what it was before the crisis you
know one of the things everybody focuses
on debt sustainability the debt to GDP
ratio if you get that GDP down low
enough that GDP goes up when the crisis
started in 2010 debt GDP ratio was 110
percent it's now much much worse because
of the flawed austerity policy that's
been imposed on Greece but so does that
mean that actually syriza is right to
runagate on on you know not what we
negotiate on the red lines or should
they just be embracing the creditors a
little bit more to at least not hackle
their backs I mean as an economist I
can't tell you the politics and I'm not
a negotiator but when I can say from the
economics they're absolutely right
that the program that was put forward
you know back in 2010 revised
subsequently
was faster that's a disaster you know
and as an economist when I saw it
originally I said this is not going to
work what's so remarkable is the ECB the
European Commission keep coming out with
forecast their models are really really
bad you know I my students I said you
know if you ever came out with with
that that a zero exactly but so why are
they so bad and how do you how do you
fix this well I think that they don't
understand the macroeconomics that when
you have austerity combined with a
weakening of the financial sector you
know that this is a fundamental
structural form a problem with the with
the EU they have the single market and
money we use countries that have a
problem and so you get the public
austerity combined with a contraction
and private lending and it's a toxic
combination the country goes down they
didn't have that built in the models the
same problem they had in failing to
forecast the 2008 crisis they didn't
learn but so should Greece actually
leaves the eurozone it would make more
sense take the pain a lot of it but then
they're in charge of their day if
Germany and the rest of your refuses to
change the program I think that there is
no alternative no the first best would
be for Europe to realize that austerity
is a mistake that there are fundamental
laws in the structure of the eurozone
professor we're too late I mean this is
you know they need money and they need
in the next couple of weeks so I
understand where what you're saying but
we just don't have the time for that if
you were Greece would you leave under
these conditions under the conditions
that the eurozone
you know refuses to change a policy that
has proven wrong led the country down
25% declining GDP I mean this is this is
this is depression like you know 50%
more than 650 percent youth unemployment
and this is destroying the country
destroying the future I think I have to
lean and say yeah you know it you know
you you bargain in good faith you did
know not everything but you did an awful
lot and they won't face up to the
realities
what happens if Greece leaves or if
Greece defaults very serious for Europe
I think it's really serious for York
because it's not only the immediate
impetus you know Greece's
small but what it's saying is this
contract this union is a temporary union
you know next time Spain has a little
bit of problem and they have a different
government people will say well you know
the European leaders don't bargain in
good faith they don't face the reality
that their policies aren't working and
they they're pushing these countries out
that means interest rates are gonna soar
you you really are bringing more
instability into Europe a real risk that
the whole European a euro project not to
you but the euro project which was
flawed from the start could be repaired
could be repaired is is going down the
tubes all right professor Stiglitz thank
you so much